so um any
answers to that question off the top of
your head let's go around
i don't feel like i'm the best person to
start this because i'm not in a
relationship so uh my relationships have
tended to fail
the best i've ever managed is
two years
but i think that um
one of the like
every relationship has been a learning
experience so i've learned something
about what not to do in a relationship
which gets me closer to what you should
do in a relationship
and i think some of the big
the the biggest failure for my most
recent relationship i think
is that we didn't have enough
arguments we tended to
work too hard to please each other and
just let things slide to keep the other
person happy
what do you think
um i think sex is
not sacred anymore and that's really
contributing to a lot of damage
yeah okay
i think that these days people are
some people are very quick to um throw
things that could potentially be good
away
i think with marriage and
relationships
it's hard work it does take commitment
it takes a lot of work
and i think these days people think are
the grass is green on the other side
whereas back in the day that wasn't you
know people worked hard for something to
make something work and they put a lot
in and it was more frowned upon to leave
a marriage
and um i think sometimes people think
it's a bit disposable these days
so they're not put in they're not
willing to put the hard work in as much
why
do people the average marriage i believe
is either seven years or nine years why
do people leave so quick do you think as
a po when you know like women from the
1920s 30s 40s like they would stay even
if their man had a family across town
yeah yeah
i
think these days um
[Music]
we are kind of sold this dream that
everything is perfect or it can be
better we've got you know very high
expectations these days i talked to my
nan like she's she's dead now but when i
used to talk to her she said oh no we
were seeing it through for you know the
long haul it wasn't something that we
would just give up on and um
i think these days
things are are a lot more disposable
like people think everything's like a
throwaway thing like more
and i think marriage is hard work like
i've been married now for
eight years together for nine and a half
and
there are times where it hasn't been
perfect and we've both like had to work
really hard we've put grafton and we've
come through the other side stronger but
if there were times when we probably
both could have said oh you know i
forget this let's you know but and when
you got married did you have the mindset
that you don't believe in divorce
yeah because i i just saw jordan
peterson talk last night and he said
that one thing um
that makes like people are so quick to
divorce because they believe in it where
and like every time they have a part a
fight with their partner their thought
is am i gonna leave
where before it was how would we work
this out
so i think
i'm not an advocate for staying in a
marriage where it's there's abuse you're
talking about sorry i'm not advocating
advocate for people staying in a
marriage that is abusive or toxic
especially if they're children involved
however i think
there are a lot of things that people
can work through
and um
[Music]
yeah i basically think that
there are things that you definitely can
work through and people aren't willing
to put that work in
um
but
i mean there are relationships that i
think kids are better off not seeing if
it's really toxic if it's abusive then
i'm all for it get out of it if it's you
know
but it doesn't always mean that the
grass is going to be greener on the
other side
um or better for the children
but um yeah i'm all about putting and
have you seen any of your friends that
got divorced and they realized it wasn't
greener um
or someone that you know
yes i have seen i mean
yeah family friends that have
you know at the time thought this is the
best thing but been a lot unhappier when
they've got out of it
um
i mean for example my mom and dad i came
from a parent a single-parent
family they split up when i was four and
i remember the day that they split up
and i was i was happy when they split up
because it was a toxic relationship and
i remember my mum telling me and feeling
really really happy that they were going
to split up but i do think um there were
a lot of relationships that you could
have put the work in and you could have
you could have come out the other side
because
you know i've looked at friends even
gone through cheating stuff and come out
the other side because they've been
willing to put um the work in and have
the faith to kind of get through it
okay what do you think michael
okay
all right repeat can you repeat the
question
um what does a healthy relationship look
like and why does our generation get it
so wrong
okay i'll say one of the primary things
is that a lot of us we come from
backgrounds where we didn't have like a
stable
like mom and dad a lot of us don't know
the dynamics of making a relationship
work i know i don't most of the people i
grew up with with boys or girls came
from single parent families so if you
haven't grown up and being like kind of
conditioned to see okay this is how you
cooperate this is how you get over
obstacles blah blah blah you know it's
not always going to be rainbows and
happy times sometimes it's going to be
you know we're bored or it's just like
monotony and stuff like that we haven't
really seen that also another thing is
like there's so many options so like
just like what you were saying about the
grasses greener and stuff like that a
lot of times you know you're looking on
instagram you're scrolling scrolling
you're looking you're looking at what
your friends are doing and stuff like
that or whoever you look at as a role
model if they're going on like you know
holidays every week going to hakkasan
and novakoff and all these places and
then you're just going nando's every
week you might even go nando's
you don't say it you might just be
eating tv dinner and you're going to be
like like this is dead right i've had
enough like so i think the internet has
got a uh yeah
um and yeah unrealistic expectations as
well so that kind of goes hand in hand
with the what i just said you know
people are just like oh i want to live
this rock star life
that's not real life and our
grandparents and even like our parents
knew that like you know i mean there was
a there was a sense of duty like you
know i'm saying it's more about family
like and and the family growing and
building an empire where everyone just
wants to everyone wants to just do it
for the grant you get what i'm saying
like so
you know and uh yeah that's about it
that's all i see i think in response to
that that um
the social media element like and the
media in general
there wouldn't have been
a few decades ago it would have been
considered a source of shame that your
relationship has failed and if you if
you were getting divorced
any attention to that would be negative
and now
it's sort of seen as uh empowerment you
know it's it's um we see celebrities
getting divorced and it's like good for
them they've they've left this
relationship and social media
women initiate more divorces than men
yeah
in general yeah so it's like you go girl
you go and go somewhere
and the the social media the falseness
of social media you will get people who
leave relationships and they're posting
all over social media how happy they are
to have left their relationship but what
they're not posting is the pictures of
them crying the second they put their
phone down you're getting drunk like
yeah
[Laughter]
have you ever been in a bar in the girls
bathroom and it's like they're all
crying
therapy sessions
it sounds like the girls are more
generous than the guys
there will be people in the bathroom
doing lines but they don't offer them
rounds
what do you think
um
a healthy relationship should um have
um its members having good um conflict
resolution skills
um a lot of
couples today just just fight and and
just keep fighting and there's nothing
that they are trying to
achieve from the fight you know just
want to be the i'm the winner i'm the
i'm i'm getting the better of the other
person
there should be a lot of mutual respect
um it's also a good idea to be
very um um
what's the word now um considerate of
the of the other person um why are the
youths getting it wrong
um there's a there's an influence of the
internet and media
the the media kind of tells young guys
today that young guys and girls today
that they should give in to their sexual
instincts
that it's okay to do that it's okay as a
man
to see a lady and the thing that you
should be appreciating about the lady is
a outward figure yes oh i like well it
starts with that
i agree the attraction starts from there
but i disagree that
that should be the focus i disagree that
there should be
that there is
a focus on that in the media if the
media is saying that oh this looks nice
or this guy looks nice but let's look at
this other part of the lady then i'll
agree that okay yeah but that's that's
not what happens the media says nothing
absolute to zero zero point zero about
character in a relationship zero about
integrity nothing but not that word okay
i think there's there's no discussion
about that in in media and the children
are going in that direction they see
that that's what we are supposed to be
looking out for in relationships it's
all materialistic
yeah like face value
i mean i did say
a very short statement which was as many
of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible